N
UKRAINIAN INFRASTRUCTURE.
JIM BITTERMANN, CNN, PARIS.
>> MORE NOW ON CNN'S EXCLUSIVE
REPORTING ON THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS FINALIZING
PLANS THIS INTO PATRIOTIC
MISSILE DEFENSE SYSTEM TO
UKRAINE.
IT'S NOT CLEAR HOW MANY MISSILE
LAUNCHES THEY WILL SEND, BUT AN
ANNOUNCEMENT CAN COME TO SPEAK.
UKRAINE HAS MADE ALMOST DAILY
REQUESTS FOR THE PATRIOTS
SYSTEM.
FOR MONTHS NOW, BIG COUNTER
RUSSIAN MISSILE ATTACKS ON
CIVILIANS AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
CAUTION TURN OUT AND CNN
MILITARY ANALYST GENERAL MARK
HURTLING, THE FORMER COMMANDING
GENERAL OF THE U.S. ARMY IN
EUROPE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
>> IT'S GOOD TO BE WITH YOU,
JOHN.
>> AS ALWAYS.
WE'LL GET TO THE OPERATIONAL
ISSUES IN A MOMENT, BUT THE BIG
THING HERE, CNN IS REPORTING
THAT THE PICTURE AS THIS LONG
RANGED, I ASKED THE TO
CAPABILITY, THAT COULD SHOOT
DOWN RUSSIAN MISSILES AND
AIRCRAFT THROUGH THEIR INTENDED
TARGETS INSIDE UKRAINE.
IF THIS HAPPENS, IT SEEMS THE
BATTLEFIELD HAS GROWN IN SIZE
AGAIN, BUT IS A DONE DEAL AT
THIS POINT?
JUST HOW FAR ALONG THE TRACK
ARE WE IN YOUR OPINION WHEN IT
COMES TO DELIVERING A PATRIOT
BATTLE DEFENSE SYSTEM TO THE
UKRAINIANS?
>> THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
UKRAINE HAS BEEN ASKING FOR FOR
A LONG TIME, JOHN, BUT I WANT
TO STATE FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING THAT THE PATRIOT
DEFENSE SYSTEM WITHIN THE
UNITED STATES MILITARY IS WHAT
IS CALLED A HIGH DEMAND, LOW
DENSITY ITEM.
THAT MEANS THERE IS NOT MANY --
KINDS OF PIECES OF EQUIPMENT.
THERE IS A LOT TO THEM, IT'S
MORE THAN JUST A MISSILE, AND
THE MUSCLE ALONE, BY THE WAY,
EACH MISSILE COST BETWEEN 3 AND
5 MILLION DOLLARS, NOT THE
LAUNCHER BUT THE MISSILE.
IT HAS MISSILES, RADARS, A
GENERATION SYSTEM AND A COMMAND
AND CONTROL SYSTEM.
THIS IS A BIG ORGANIZATION THAT
DOES HAVE LONG RANGE AND HIGH
ALTITUDE CAPABILITY OF SHUTTING
DOWN --
IT'S DESIGNED TO SHOOT DOWN
LARGE AIRCRAFTS AND CREWS
MISSES, SO THIS IS NOT ONE OF
THOSE SYSTEMS YOU WOULD USE
AGAINST DRONES OR SOME OF THE
TYPES OF MISSILES THAT RUSSIA
HAS BEEN FIRING, OR IT SHOULD
NOT BE THAT TYPE.
YOU COULD BE WASTING A LOT OF
MONEY TO DO THE.
THE OTHER THING IS, IT TAKES A
LOT OF PEOPLE, AND IT TAKES A
LOT OF MAINTENANCE AND SUPPLIES
TO KEEP THESE BATTERIES
RUNNING.
IT IS A VERY LARGE SYSTEM, IT
HAS A LOT OF PEOPLE IN, AND THE
TRAINING, TRUTHFULLY, JOHN,
I'VE SEEN BASIC TRAINING FOR
THOSE WHO FIRES MISSILES, AND
THE REPAIRMAN AND SUPPLIERS, IT
TAKES NOT WEEKS BUT MONTHS, AND
IN SOME CASES, YEARS, TO LEARN
THE SYSTEM.
UKRAINE HAS BEEN VERY GOOD,
THEY ADAPTED SOME OF THE
SYSTEMS WE'VE GIVEN THEM, AND
THEY'VE DONE IT WELL.
THIS IS A VERY COMPLEX AND HIGH
TECHNOLOGY PIECE OF EQUIPMENT
THAT TAKES A LONG TIME TO
LEARN.
>> TO YOUR POINT, THE U.S. ARMY
DESCRIBED THE PATRIOT AS ITS
MOST ADVANCED AIR DEFENSE
SYSTEM, CAPABLE OF DEFEATING
BOTH HIGH PERFORMANCE AIRCRAFT
AND TACTICAL BALLISTIC
MISSILES.
IT HAS A PHASED ARRAY --
PARDONING EQUIPMENT, UP TO 8
WATCHERS, EACH WHICH HOLDS FOR
READY TO FIRE MISSILES, THAT'S
WHEN THE WATCH THEIR.
AS YOU SAY, UKRAINIANS HAVE
BEEN REMARKABLY ADEPT AT
LEARNING, BUT THIS IS A WHOLE
BEAST ALTOGETHER.
CNN IS REPORTING THAT CHENEY
COULD ACTUALLY TAKE PLACE AT A
U.S. BASE, SOMEWHERE IN GERMANY,
SO IN TERMS OF ESCALATION FROM
THE VIEW OF MOSCOW, HOW WOULD
THEY SEE THAT?
>> THEY WOULD SEE IT AS
ESCALATION, BUT THE QUESTION
THAT I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
WOULD RESPOND WITH IS, SO WHAT?
YOU KNOW, THEY HAVE BEEN
ESCALATING THIS WAR, KILLING
CIVILIANS, ABDUCTING ILLEGAL
ACTIVITIES, STRIKING
INFRASTRUCTURE TARGETS, CAUSING
THE CIVILIAN POPULATION OF
UKRAINE GREAT PAIN, SO IT IS
ONLY AN ESCALATION TO DEAL WITH
THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT RUSSIA
HAS BEEN DOING, SO THEY MAY SEE
IT AS AN ESCALATORY RESPONSE,
BY THE UNITED STATES AND OTHER
NATO COUNTRIES TO PROVIDE THIS
KIND OF EQUIPMENT, BUT IT IS
WHAT UKRAINE'S THE MANSE
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO PROTECT
THEIR CITIZENS FROM AN ILLEGAL
WAR.
>> AND YOU HAVE BEEN QUICK TO
HIGHLIGHT THE FACT THAT IT'S
NOT JUST THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
PAGER SYSTEM BUT ALSO THE HIGH
NUMBER OF PERSONNEL NEED TO
KEEP IT IN OPERATION.
FOR CONTEXT, THIS IS NOT THE
BATTERY, IF IT BATTALION AIR
DEFENSE ARTILLERY, POSTING FOR
A PHOTO ON A COMMISSION IN
POLAND JUST LAST AUGUST.
USUALLY ABOUT 90 SOLDIERS ARE
ASSIGNED TO A BATTERY, BUT ONLY
3 ARE NEEDED FOR COMBAT
PURPOSES.
WHAT ARE THE CHANCES, IF THIS
GOES AHEAD, SOME OF THOSE 90
PERSONNEL SUPPORT WILL BE U.S.
TROOPS.
>> I CAN'T SPEAK TO THAT,
TRUTHFULLY, BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT AND THE SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE HAVE BOTH SAID THAT
THERE WILL BE NO U.S. SOLDIERS
ON THE GROUND INSIDE OF
UKRAINE.
THAT'S THE PROBLEMATIC PIECE OF
THIS.
IT MUST BE UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS
THAT ARE TRAINED IN THIS,
UNLESS WE CHANGE OUR POLICY,
UNLESS THE PRESIDENT SAYS, NO,
I'LL AND MILITARY PERSONNEL IN.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ON THE INTERNET
ARE SAYING, WHY DON'T WE JUST
SEND CONTRACTORS?
CONTRACTORS ARE THE SAME KIND
OF PROBLEMATIC THINGS.
THEY ARE NORMALLY AMERICAN
CONTRACTORS, BECAUSE THAT'S
WHO'S DEVELOP THE SYSTEM.
SO YOU STILL HAVE AMERICANS ON
THE GROUND INSIDE OF A WAR
BETWEEN RUSSIA AND UKRAINE, SO
THAT IS PROBLEMATIC.
I DON'T FORESEE THAT POLICY
CHANGING BY THE PRESIDENT, SO
IT IS A REQUIREMENT TO TRAIN
UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS AND THEIR
SUPPORTERS ARE THESE VERY
COMPLEX PIECES OF EQUIPMENT.
AS YOU SAID BEFORE, THERE ARE
RUMORS THAT IT MAY BE TRAINED
IN GERMANY, THE TRAINING BASE
IN GERMANY IS ONE THAT I
COMMANDED IN SOUTHERN BAVARIAN.
THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE THE
CAPABILITY TO LAUNCH MISSILES
AT THAT LOCATION BECAUSE THE
RANGES ARE TOO SMALL.
THEY COULD CERTAINLY DO
SIMULATION TRAINING, AND THEY
COULD LEARN THE PIECES OF
EQUIPMENT, BUT YOU WOULD NOT
GET ANY LIVE LUNCHES AT THE
EQUIPMENT DOWN THERE.
IF IT ALL BE IN SIMULATIONS, IF
THEY DECIDE TO DO IT.
>> THERE'S OBVIOUSLY, IT SEEMS,
A LOT TO GO BEFORE THIS BECOMES
REALITY, SIR.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, GENERAL
HURTLING, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> ALWAYS A PLEASURE, JOHN,
THANKS.
>> TROOP READINESS IN BELARUS
IS SPARKING CONCERNS THAT
RUSSIA'S LONGTIME ALLY MAY BE
OPENING TO OPEN A 2ND EFFORT IN
UKRAINE.
SOME NOTES EARLIER THIS YEAR
JUST BEFORE RUSSIA INVADED
UKRAINE, BUT AS CNN'S WILL
RIPLEY REPORTS, THIS TIME, THE
UKRAINIANS ALREADY.
>> WE JUST ARRIVED AT A
UKRAINIAN MILITARY FORD
OPERATING BASE HERE AT THE
BELARUSIAN BORDER, WHERE THEY
WILL SHOW US THE FORTIFICATIONS
THAT THEY HAVE PUT IN PLACE TO
PROTECT AGAINST A POTENTIAL
RUSSIAN GROUND INVASION.
>> A FEW MILES AWAY IN
NEIGHBORING BELARUS, AND
OMINOUS SHOW OF FORCE.
RUSSIAN AND BELARUSIAN TROOPS
HOLDING GOING TO COMBAT DRILLS,
LIKE THEY DID EARLIER THIS YEAR,
JUST BEFORE THE INVASION.
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT THE
TROOP BUILDUP ON THE BELARUSIAN
BORDER?
>> WE HAVE TO BE CONCERNED
BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT FRIENDLY
NEIGHBOR, BUT WE HAVE 2500
KILOMETERS NOT FRIENDLY BORDERS,
BROTHERS, RUSSIA AND THE
OCCUPIED TERRITORIES.
WE HAD TO BE CAREFUL HERE.
>> THE DEFENSE MINISTER TELLS
CNN THAT UKRAINE IS PREPARING
IN CASE THE RUSSIANS INVADE
FROM BELARUS AGAIN.
HE SAYS THEY URGENTLY NEED MORE
WEAPONS, ANTI TANK SYSTEMS,
MORE ADVANCED MISSILE DEFENSE.
>> TRANSLATOR: WE ARE NOT
AFRAID OF THEM, SAYS THE
CAPTAIN, DIMITRI.
WE DO NOT EXPECT HIM TO COME
HERE, BUT THEY DO, WE WILL BE
READY.
THE SOLDIERS ARE CONSTANTLY
REHEARSING, READY AT A MOMENTS
NOTICE.
>> YOU THINK THE RUSSIANS WILL
TRY ANYTHING?
>> LET THEM TRY, SAYS IGOR.
>> BEFORE THE WAR, HE PREPARED
SEWING MACHINES.
NOW, HE DRIVES THIS.
>> HOW QUICKLY CAN YOU GET GUYS
TO THE FRONT IF YOU NEED TO?
>> IT WILL BE VERY FAST, HE
SAYS.
THEY STARTED BUILDING THESE
TRENCHES IN EARLY APRIL,
REINFORCING THEM EVER SINCE.
GETTING READY FOR THE RUSSIANS
THEY OVERPOWERED UKRAINIAN
DEFENSES AT THE START OF THE
WAR.
6 WEEKS, AND THOUSANDS OF
DEATHS NATIONWIDE LATER,
SOLDIERS FROM THIS PART ITALIAN
HELPED FORCE THEM OUT.
>> WAS THERE EVER A POINT WHERE
IT WAS OVERWHELMING, THAT YOU
THOUGHT YOU CAN'T DO THIS, WE
CAN'T FIGHT THEM OFF?
>> I NEVER FELT LIKE, THAT SAYS
THIS MAN, BECAUSE I KNOW THERE
IS NO WAY BACK.
WE HAVE FAMILIES AT HOME, WE
HAVE CHILDREN.
>> HE SAYS THAT 2500 RUSSIAN
VEHICLES ACTUALLY PASSED RIGHT
DOWN THIS ROAD.
>> NOW, WE'RE DRIVING DOWN THE
SAME ROAD TO A BRIDGE NEAR THE
BORDER, WELL WITHIN RUSSIAN
ARTILLERY RANGE.
>> WHEN THE RUSSIANS INVADED
MORE THAN 9 MONTHS AGO, THEY
JUST DROVE DOWN THIS ROAD RIGHT
OVER THIS BRIDGE, BUT NOW THE
BRIDGE HAS BEEN RIGGED WITH
EXPLOSIVES, AND THE SWAMPLANDS,
WHICH ARE FROZEN OVER, ARE FULL
OF MINDS.
>> WHEN THE FIRST CONVOY OF AN
ESTIMATED 30,000 RUSSIANS CAME
IN FEBRUARY, UKRAINIANS WERE
UNPREPARED AND OUTNUMBERED 6-1.
NOW, LIKE SOLDIERS FROM A
CENTURY AGO, THEY HUNKER DOWN
IN THE TRENCHES, WAITING F